[Musique]
je ne sais pas quoi dire je ne m'étais
pas j'ai envie de faire ça ou ça ou ça
je crois que c'est toujours ce qu'on
croit nous on se fait toujours des idées
sur soir c'est à dire on se dit toujours
tiens si je faisais ça ça serait
formidable pour moi je crois que les
metteurs en scène quelqu'un qui vous
voient d'un oeil différent
je crois qu'on se regarde très mal soi
même je crois que les autres voient
beaucoup mieux
je crois qu'il faut laisser au moins on
interprète quelque chose il faut laisser
le faire le choix il faut pas faire le
choix se soit même je crois pas enfin
pour moi je parle ce qui concerne j'en
doute
je crois que ça a été une époque très
importante pour moi il pas seulement sur
le plan professionnel mais aussi sur un
plan humain parce que c'est pile c'est
lui qui m'a qui m'a appris presque tout
enfin le plus que je sais c'est notre
histoire
un peintre qui fait le portrait de la
femme tu veux que je continue je crois
que
pour jean-luc je crois pas que c'est
terminé parce que pour ceux qui pour
ceux qui ont aimé les films qui a fait
avec moi je crois que c'était faux ce
qui reste bon je crois qu'on dit
toujours responsable de ce qu'on fait
est libre je lève la main jusqu'aux
responsables
je tourne la tête à toi je suis
responsable je suis malheureuse jusque
responsable on en dehors de ça je n'ai
pas seulement tourné avec jean luc
godard
j'en ai fait beaucoup d'autres car j'ai
tourné cinq films avec lui j'en ai fait
environ 17
ce qu'ils étaient moi j'aime
personnellement j'aime beaucoup ces
films je crois que que c'est les mieux
[Musique]